it goes without saying that ace and his
role in the story of one piece have been
a wildly controversial topic many adore
his character for it's cool and charming
design while many others criticize it
for its lack of character development
and impulsive behavior and at the height
of this debate stands of course the
climax of Asus tragic story arc his
defeat by Blackbeard is captured by the
Marines his liberation by Luffy and
finally his sacrifice for his younger
brother a common point of criticism
regarding Asus death is that ace did not
have enough character development to
make his death feel impactful enough and
while emotional connection to a
character is and always will be a
subjective experience for every one of
us I find that this argument is somewhat
missing the point of Asus role in the
story because not every character in a
story can or even should undergo
character development in fact there are
three types of character are ecstatic
character can go through positive change
negative change or no change at all
ace just as many other important side
characters in the story has a flat
character arc meaning he doesn't change
his view on the world but stays a
constant throughout his appearances in
the story his entire life
ace is struggling with the legacy of his
father's name having to suffer under
both the burning hatred as well as the
flaming admiration people had for Roger
being born as the son of the worst
criminal of his age until his very last
moment ace is struggling to find meaning
in his life and whether he ever deserved
to live in the first place the one thing
he can cling on to is his burning will
to protect his friends and family from
any harm his death therefore was one of
the most shocking events in the entirety
of one piece especially so since Oda is
very careful and averse when it comes to
killing of characters and most
importantly ASUS death was not a Disney
death where the person suddenly comes
back to life in the end know what makes
this moment so incredibly powerful is
that it is final and
real consequences and therefore in this
video I want to talk about the tragedy
of portgas the ace and why his death is
one of the fundamental cornerstones of
the wampie story because Luffy losing
his beloved older brother not only
deepens our protagonist character but it
also advances the plot in a crucial way
and of course also impacts us the
readers emotionally when I talk about
how aces death has deepened Luffy's
character I believe it goes much deeper
than simply showing Luffy that he has to
become stronger in fact Luffy already
was aware of this back on water 7 when
he talks to Bruno about his devastating
defeat by LKG and of course losing his
crew to Kees ruined Cunha against both
of whom he stood not the slightest
chance also made Luffy realized that he
had to become much more powerful so no
aces death was not simply a way for
Luffy to become stronger losing his
treasured older brother whom he had
shared such a happy and adventurous
childhood with shook luffy to his core
and from there developed his character
fundamentally having his loving bond
with his brother cut just when he had
managed to finally do the impossible and
save him from the marines through luffy
into deep distress and despair being
characterized by his positive easygoing
and at times in the evening
Luffy has to learn that not every
obstacle can be overcome through
determination alone for the first time
ever he was not able to fulfill a goal
he set himself he gave everything he had
to save his brother and he still failed
he realizes that loss and failure are
things that can actually happen to him
if he's not willing to take things
seriously but it goes even further than
this it makes Luffy question his entire
purpose for setting out to see losing
both his crew and ace is an absolute low
point in his adventure however the
experience allows him to realize that
his crew are not only his friends but
family and that he has to grow
significantly in order to be able to
protect them from aces fate
thus he literally inherits aces will to
protect those he holds dear at any cost
it is the decisive trigger for Luffy to
become the powerful and more mature
captain that he is today and finally
seeing his brother murdered in front of
his own eyes also gave Luffy his first
ever antagonist that he resents on a
personal level
killing ace and literally burning the
mark of his death into Lucy's chest is a
permanent visual reminder of what the
Admiral did to our protagonist in the
end Luffy comes out of his grief as a
stronger wiser and overall more mature
captain facing a strong antagonist that
he truly resents with all his heart
but ASIS tragic character arc does even
more for the story than just developing
Luffy it advances the plotline
significantly and sets the stage for the
second half of the story
well some people disliked aces defeat by
Blackbeard and his subsequent capture by
the Marines these events not only
introduced Blackbeard as Luffy's biggest
rival for the story but it also placed
Luffy as aces little brother right at
the center of the imple down at marine
for arts this was crucial
since both arcs did not only introduce a
ton of new important characters but also
rang in the end of rogers and white bits
era and the beginning of the new age
since s wanted to make white beard king
of the Pirates and white beard in turn
to make a spirit King there was very
little room for Luffy to come closer to
his goal
this new power vacuum created by white
beards death was not only convenient but
necessary for both Luffy and Blackbeard
to have a realistic shot at finding the
one piece and this war taking place and
Luffy being able to be present there was
only possible because his adopted
brother
the son of the former pirate king
himself was to be publicly executed and
politicized by the world government and
beside that the war and luffy's tragic
loss also served as a midpoint climax to
the entire series which gave the
adventure a fresh start of the time skip
and better pacing overall in this
context it also allowed us to see Luffy
reflect upon his childhood with ace and
Sabo and thus gave us a much deeper look
into the development and history of his
character so to put it shortly
aces character was designed to enable
crucial plot development for the one
piece story that resulted in one of the
most popular arcs of the series and also
set the stage for the second half of the
adventure in the new world
now it would be quite heartless of me of
course
to say that Asus character was simply an
elegant tool smartly fit into the story
to develop Luffy and the plots because
as I said at the beginning for many days
was a deeply likeable character thus his
death obviously had a strong emotional
impact on his readers as well however
even if you did not like or care for ace
too much before his execution I think
that the moment he died was nonetheless
powerful for pretty much any reader
because not only that a sacrifices just
be gained life for his little brother
Luffy but Oda also found a quite
emotional and yet weirdly satisfying end
to his character arc firstly the true
magnitude of a minor characters death is
always defined by the reaction of the
hero who we all emphasize with and
luffy's reaction to aces death might
very well be the most powerful and
heartbreaking thing we've had to witness
in the entire series so far this fact
alone gave this moment and thus aces
character a lot of meaning actually
making him even more popular after his
death and secondly ace finally managed
to find an answer to the question that
has haunted him his entire life why do I
live all his life ace was known for
never turning his back on an enemy no
matter how strong they were and when he
finally accepts white beard and his men
as his new family he proudly wears his
mark on his back where it could never be
harmed and yet despite this pride the
last thing he does is turning his back
on a canoe in order to protect his
family having Luffy and white beard
taking on the world government itself
for his sake shows him that people
actually do care whether he lives or not
he actually deserves to live and so just
having found his answer he chooses to
protect his family over all else and
this will he then inherits - Luffy
what we can take away from all this is
that Asus character is much more than a
cool older brother whose death motivated
Luffy to train for two years and get
stronger know the hardship and doubt
that he carried in his heart for his
entire life as well as the love that he
felt for his family led to the most
impactful event in the story up to this
point not only did he give significant
character development to Luffy but he
also shaped and developed a plot of the
story in a number of crucial ways and in
the end his death drove home one of the
most if not the most important theme in
one piece
following your dreams because with ace
dying in the end with a smile on his
face just as his father did Oda tells us
that if you pursue your dream and strive
for what you really wanted in life you
will have a happy ending
[Music]
hey everyone thank you so much for
watching what are your thoughts on ace
and the story and what character would
you like to see me discuss next share
your thoughts with me in the comments
below if you enjoy one piece and want to
learn more about storytelling world
building or my thoughts on the latest
one piece chapter make sure to LIKE and
subscribe to become part of the channel
right now I hope to see around next time
and until then stay safe and have a
wonderful week
you
you